the movie opens on Saturday June 21st
1941 in the city park of breast we are
introduced to a 15-year-old musician
named Sasha akimov who is serving in the
333rd rifle Regiment of the Red Army at
the breast Fortress Sasha lives with his
older brother Andre after losing their
parents in the Spanish Civil War he has
an affection for a girl named Ana who is
the daughter of Lieutenant Andre kitov
the scene then cuts to the breast train
station where a crowd of residents are
seen rushing to board trains in order to
leave turns out there is a rumor that
the city will soon be attacked by the
German Nazi troops a commissar named Yim
fman also arrives at the station only to
discover that he is unable to bring his
family to breast due to a shortage of
train tickets meanwhile another officer
named gavrilov talks to the officer of
the nkvd special Department Lieutenant
vinin expressing his concern about the
Readiness of the fort's defenses should
an attack come he points out that if the
Germans attack them they will be trapped
and will not be able to get out of the
fort moreover the soldiers in the fort
numbered around 8,000 people including
the wives and children would be
difficult to evacuate however vainstein
does not take the matter seriously which
causes gavrilov to become Furious
prompting him to walk away later in the
middle of the night thousands of Nazi
Germans infiltrate the breast train
station under the disguise of the Soviet
Union Army as the first step of their
plan they cut off electricity and water
supply before starting to surround the
fort at 3:58 a.m. in the morning the
German forces begin their invasion of
the Soviet Union The Fortress gets
subjected to heavy bombardment by German
artillery and Shuka aircraft killing
many Soviet soldiers and civilians this
unexpected attack sets Panic among the
civilians prompting them to run for
their lives one after another the
buildings are destroyed causing
pandemonium by 6:30 a.m. the German
troops start to move towards the
Fortress capturing and killing Hospital
staff and patients terrified the
civilians try to get out of the fort
through the north gate but they are also
gunned down fman then takes command of
the Defenders around the col gate and as
the soldiers take their positions on the
Windows he orders his troops not to let
the enemy soldiers cross the bridge in
front of the fort simultaneously
gavrilov organizes Defenders around the
Eastern fort in response to the
unexpected and devastating attack
elsewhere the nkvd Border guards under
command of Lieutenant kitov act on
repelling a German sorti into the
Fortress despite being low on ammo he
orders his troops to attack the enemies
with their makeshift weapons after an
intense battle katav and his soldiers
are eventually able to repel a batch of
German soldiers however in the process
several of their own men are killed on
the other hand an undercover German
Soldier pretends to be a lieutenant and
approaches veinstein in an attempt to
undermine the defense of the 132nd
independent nkvd Convoy Battalion
Barracks he instructs veinstein and his
soldiers to split into small groups and
abandon the fort however the disguise
does not go smoothly as vainstein
manages to uncover the truth due to
different shoe designs the Soviet Union
army boots have round spikes while the
German boots have square spikes the
Germans need better fashion designers
realizing the deception veinstein reacts
swiftly shooting the undercover Soldier
to death at the col gate fman notices
the German soldiers crossing the bridge
holding civilians hostage in a quick
action he orders his soldiers to wait
for his signal and then walks outside
figing surrender while negotiating with
the Germans fman suddenly instructs the
hostages to get down after which his
troops open fire neutralizing the enemy
and rescuing the civilians following
this he assigns one of his soldiers to
drive to the city in order to alert
their headquarters the soldier heads out
but is shocked to discover the piles of
corpses of Soviet soldiers as well as
the civilians at the northern gate
causing him to retreat he returns back
to fman and reports that the north gate
can no longer be passed not long after a
German military tank enters through the
same gate crushing all the corpses
brutally simultaneously several other
military tanks enter through the Eastern
Gate as well upon seeing this gavrilov
immediately mobilizes his troops to
prepare with improvised weapons and take
their positions as the enemy soldiers
approach a cannon suddenly hits one of
the German tanks gabov looks around and
notices that Andre and another Soldier
are firing a 45mm anti-tank gun at their
best speed to take down the enemy tank
however their efforts don't last long as
one of the tanks soon locates them and
blows them up resulting in their deaths
after this gabov gives the green signal
to his soldiers prompting all of them to
launch their attacks the Soviet Union
armies fight with great courage and
bravery eventually managing to finish
off the German soldiers by the end of
June 22nd the Soviet Defenders are
divided into groups one force under fman
defending the colem gate a second Force
Under gavrilov defending the Eastern
redout while kitov defends the ninth
Frontier Outpost along with a group of
civilians and vainstein holds on to the
barracks of the 132nd nkvd Battalion on
the foll following morning the German
soldiers make an announcement for the
residents leaving them with two choices
surrender themselves or die in a hail of
bullets Sasha who is still alive does
not believe the Germans words and heads
towards the troops of lieutenant kitov
in a building the boy then asks gatov
about Ana because he last saw her
running towards her father when the
lieutenant remains silent Sasha makes a
brave decision to go out in danger in
search of her in the midst of his search
he comes across a group of Fan's troops
interrogating a German soldier the
captive Soldier reveals that the city of
Minsk which was the main defense center
of the Soviet Union has already been
destroyed however fman does not believe
in him as he is confident that the
Soviet Union Soldiers won't be defeated
that easily a short while later an i16
Soviet fighter aircraft of the 123rd
fighter Aviation regiment is seen flying
in the sky which raises hope in the
suffering soldiers but just a few
seconds later the aircraft is shot down
by enemy planes the only good thing is
that the pilot manages to land safely
via parachute seeing this Fan's troops
immediately rush to him and bring him to
safety fman then asks him about the
situation of the headquarters and the
reason why the backup has not arrived
yet in response the pilot replies that
all of their bases are destroyed and the
cities have been occupied by the Nazi
Germans as a result all the survivors
are retreating toward Minsk this Grim
news shatters the solders hopes
realizing that they now have to fight
tooth and nail against the invading
Germans without any help from
headquarters in addition to their
hardship the residents face severe
shortage of food and water plunging them
into great desperation on June 24th fman
makes a tough decision to break out of
the fort even though they have to face
an overwhelming number of armed German
Army he instructs his soldiers to write
down the plan on a piece of paper and
then pass it on to another group so that
they can all act at the same time just
then the German troops launch another
attack on Fan's group prompting the
soldiers to retaliate hastily before
joining in the gunfight fman orders two
of his soldiers to pass the breakout
message to another group hearing this
Sasha also volunteers to join in the
delivering Mission but the commander
denies his request regardless the boy
who has a very high Spirit of
nationalism decides to carry out the
mission alone in the middle of his
journey the Nazi Germans launched their
next Air Attack on the fort which
results in the explosion of more
buildings the soldiers assigned to
deliver the message suffer severe
injuries in this assault as a result
Sasha who somehow manages to survive the
explosions is the only hope now as the
boy makes his way to the other group he
unexpectedly meets Ana who is now in a
very weakened State despite their Joy at
seeing each other Sasha insists he
cannot take her with him right now
however he promises to come back for her
after delivering the crucial message
upon continuing on his way he passes
through the completely overrun 132nd
Battalion along with the lifeless body
of vainstein despite the Grim situation
the boy manages to maintain his
composure and ultimately succeeds in
delivering the message to kitov and
gavrilov that night after receiving a
flare gun signal from fman all three
remaining groups set out from their
respective places for the breakout
however their plan does not go as
expected because the Germans start
shooting down all the soldiers resulting
in a massacre after suffer suffering a
huge loss of soldiers the Soviet Union
armies are forced to retreat back to
their hideouts as the sun rises we see a
grim sight the entire Fort is filled
with corpses realizing that they can't
win over the German soldiers katav
orders the surviving civilians including
his wife and daughter to vacate the
Fortress during a ceasefire his wife
Katya initially refuses to leave without
him but he convinces her that being a
soldier's wife it is her responsibility
to to lead the other civilians out the
couple then shares an emotional hug for
one last time before parting ways at the
same time Sasha brings Ana to join the
civilians seeing his daughter still
alive katav runs over to her and hugs
her tight he then orders Sasha and Anya
to join the group of civilians Sasha
hesitates citing his responsibility to
the nation but the lieutenant entrusts
him with the responsibility of taking
care of Ana after all the civilians make
it out of the Fortress the Germans
soldiers drop a 2ton bomb with the
intention of obliterating the entire
place in the aftermath they start
checking every nook and cranny of the
fort eradicating the surviving Pockets
The Defenders at colem gate are forced
to surrender and fman is immediately
executed by a German firing squad on the
other hand gavrilov orders his remaining
men to attempt to break out individually
while he stays behind as a result he is
apprehended as a prisoner of war and
tortured brutally in the meantime an
injured kitov and his surviving men
manag to regroup in the barracks not
long after Sasha returns to meet them
there he claims that he managed to flee
the civilian group and is here to
fulfill his duty katav in return hands
him the regimental colors and asks him
to remember the truth about the
Defenders with this the lieutenant
orders his surviving soldiers to leave
while he stays back and takes a machine
gun to cover them despite their best
efforts the breakout proves futile and
the remaining defenders in including
katov are killed the only one who
manages to escape is Sasha finally the
breast Fortress ends up falling in the
hands of the Nazi Germans the scene then
cuts to several decades later and we see
an elderly Sasha paying tribute to the
memorial of breast Fortress accompanied
by his grandson the movie ends as he
reminisces about the good old days and
the memories of life before the Nazis
took
everything subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching